hey we're here in South Africa to check
out the world cup but also we're here to
find out the history of the vuvuzela now
if you don't know what a vuvuzela is
it's a long and it's really interesting
because it we actually found out that
the vuvuzela had its origins in the
midnight a guy named invented it from a
boom and there's been a lot of
controversy about it mostly from people
in the vuvuzela community who are very
angry when soccer games actually break
out when they're trying to play their
movies Ellis you can now get a vuvuzela
app for your iPhone even if your
vuvuzela gets compensated and you can
make the vuvuzela sound just like this